nice pass from Georgia 13 books on the
try playing grade right now getting out
on the break
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you make the pass to Kawhi Leonard
he understands I need to make the pass
right to balls yours to give it up
you changes gear for dog and penny
[Music]
let's look here at bold George great job
by the camera
[Music]
[Applause]
Paul George taking one
four or five seven we can't let
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Larry Bird shot that he made back in the
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
operate in this area please very good
ice with our spinner got the spin cycle
mysteriously the soul
[Music]
[Applause]
cousin possession Paul George with the
bounce pass
why catches and finishes
Astro Boy Scout therefore rivers
[Applause]
watch your step how about this right
here it must be nice to be able to move
that fast
[Music]
[Applause]
well George
needless to say
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I was a big-time play by big-time player
once in a while what up at your boy Adam
left codes you like that content I know
you like that content hit subscribe for
more of it from Bleacher Report